tauchen ab in vergangenheit zurück ins
herz von schweizer nieberg auf der suche
nach seiner kenntnis
[Musik]
es ist vom 24
denn wird schweizer großer teil vor den
arbeiterführer und verbraucher mit
bewaffneten festigen
waren sie auch zander sieht die
anlagedauer casey dass er ins gefängnis
quadratisch oder verraten hat und schuf
bilder hat mir bis vor einem jahr
nun ist dort veröffentlichen es ist wird
regierung mit dem harz vor schweiz auf
dem vierwaldstättersee hypothetische
grenzen so gehetzt bis dahin gegangen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier an der einstichstelle vom see
zwischen der oberen und der unteren als
defizit modellen für die
grenzbefestigung extranet schweizer
marina aufbauen aber noch keinen motor
musste improvisieren und auf private
briefe mann mit der waffe ausgerüstet
[Musik]
mit dem herz der militärrat der uri
fahren mit dem hans jacob burckhardt
unser ufer sehen diese später
funktioniert hat
wo war die abwehr gestanden uns darauf
verständigen wie der oberen aus links
runderen aus rechts alles verbunkert im
felsen ändern aber zusätzlich hat man
als unikat wie thomann schritt setzt das
so schnitt geht man als schwimmende sehr
schwierig machen das ist kein durchgang
1,2 kilometer lang links vor der oberen
ausweg und da in dem buch die ägypter
nach einer hartz und gar kein haus weit
dass auch dank das ist dank sieben sind
also damals die deutsche wehrmacht mit
kokowääh rüber dass die geräte wie das
ist ja der rede ganz oder mit
wasserflugzeug
deutsch infos versteckt und biss von
banja strang kam ist die bewaffnete
bungalow zur befestigung aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg wird die oberin aus der fred
böhme für pv anlage erzeugt mit beamer
mit der goldkante schießscharten von
bargeld an sich
[Musik]
schilder mit einzelnen der aufwand das
ist das wichtigste der menschen gekommen
die sich stets mit
das heißt mit state of tour
das war also der standort judenburg der
selber mit findet ruhig kommen
hiernach
die befestigt die csp die opera und
unter die nase einmal egal ob das
militär hut nehmen muss politik braucht
[Musik]
erst im september 1990 mit dem
schauspieler bricht der hitler als
gültig die brüchigkeit europa trafen vom
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schweiz bleibt weitgehend verschont und
kirche projekt generation von migros
ältere stark fragt was erhöhte
archivraum nachlass und bürger ist für
sie die kirche die realität sie
die deutsche truppe für igor achter
blitz frankreich kapituliert show im
juni 1940 europa bestellen oder
schweizer regierung verkündet der
bevölkerung via radio wie sie jetzt hat
vorgang der bundespräsident köhler hätte
nie umstritten
diese situation abbas lehnte die schweiz
müsse nun sogar bedroht perspektive
deutschlands dreht vom bundespräsidenten
volk mit gut darum der tscheche jakub
janda erklärt warum die räte hätten
schmerzen die wir kick im mietpreis von
der bevölkerung ist jetzt ist er gierig
war steht jeder irgendwo zwar wir jetzt
ist defätismus seine politischen spitze
nach oben nicht resignierte und mutlose
politik container warum folgt er glaube
an die eigene stärke zurück gitarre
gesang
am 30 august 1909 gries quad
bundesversammlung zum generator der
schweiz und anfängt etc
die richtige wort
persönlich glaube ich nicht nur an die
notwendigkeit und dann die pflicht
sondern auch an die wirksame möglichkeit
und zu verteidigen verteidigen heißt in
diesem falle nicht nur halten sondern
sich mit aller kraft tragen zerstören
sein leben so teuer wie möglich eine
dringliche abbau und der general muteten
folgt ziemlich viel zu planen oder der
schweizerinnen und schweizer präsentiert
ich zwar nicht ganz neu aber toll küren
der general propagiert der rückzug von
der truppe die deutschbanker
10 des schweizers niere förmig stück hat
mehrtägige mit dem gotthard im zentrum
der plan wurde general drama und ein
volk müsse plausibel machen
schweiz in den opener bunker verrückte
idee aber der general guisan hätte
sicher psychologisches gespür und sucht
sich als symbolträchtiges für seine
botschaft der versammlung die gesamte
armeespitze auf dem dampfschiff stadt
luzern und führte offen firat stadtbusse
am rücken zu fast 70 jahre später
griffen crew von generali sondermodell
ist ob der ehemalige swissair pilot
beurteilt strategie von großvater
damit mitunter aber offenbar seit der
lage gemacht und sind so groß dass die
praxis des bundesvorstandes gestartet
das ist beklagenswert
rund 500 offizier von mallorca hat am 25
juli 1940 richtige wachs diskret bewacht
von 0° ein bewaffneter polizist der
oberste vor am längsten dauern hingegen
raum hat weiß man dass ein offizier mit
der nazis sympathisiert eher auslöser
deutschland hatte sie sich ändert
wünscht nicht zurückzog
der ort für sie folge schwarzwald oder
sonic vor ungefähr zwei generationen
zwei zähler vor wehrhafte schweiz und
strich sich widerstandslos
manuskriptblätter jetzt nicht gleich
sein dann hätte einfach sein bestand
historischen ort und das klappt aber
verteidigen und mit trauben und die
ganze armee und schweizer werte sind
auch sie von passieren
clark vor schweigt sich zu dem zeitpunkt
tatsächlich bäckt betreuung vom ausland
her massiv und schwierige schätzen
fast gleichzeitig mit der kapitulation
vor frankreich trifft italia energie die
unheilige allianz hitler mussolini und
voll zum tragen
das vergebliche italien
ich muss die geniale schöpferische
tätigkeit eines gestalteten mannes zu
einem neuen imperium geworden wie benito
mussolini
wichtig ist dass unsere beiden völker
wir menschen die gewaltige und wachsende
masse und 115 millionen betragen
zusammen stellen in eine einzige der
unerschütterlichen endstation
[Applaus]
die schweiz schlag mit dem rücken
rapport sturm vor der facebook-gruppe
große masse der schweiz war der
gigantische aktionscode im gebirge
unzählige schwer bewaffnet die bunker
und festungsanlage wasser und abwasser
um herum gesehen
[Musik]
hamm viele soldaten schlosser in den
bergen
das war die trixie industriemetall an
die bevölkerung steht mit den frohsinn
war immer als im nordbereich sie
empfängt auslieferung aus heutiger sicht
kaum nachvollziehbar da zwar hetzte
anschluss vom general breite
zustimmungen weg seid mir können sie
zurück aber das heißt nicht dass mir das
passiert sondern dass mir zeige dass
mich das schon wieder im kanton glarus
die ganz besuch zum brot
[Musik]
eine trick mit geglaubt und erhöht große
bewunderung
warum sie jetzt doch vor zwei wochen und
monate nach zitierte er stellt sich vor
alleine hund voralb druck auf der
anderen seite drückte rappold tanze
verkörpert das hätte gucken dass wir in
der woche waren richtig hätte veh gerade
nicht mehr an der stadt bonn zu bekommen
was man kann sagen sexy prager tanzen
sagt dobernig und hielt und dem weg von
oder und neiße paul motto kann man
erwarte jedoch das hätte eine fehlt ist
aber dass nowitzki ja das hat man gegen
die akzeptiert position sagt man halt
akzeptiert dass man sich zurückziehen
derweil hätten uns 140 im gotthard bitte
festes gruppe aktiv dienst geleistet
erst ende zwanzig frisch aus der
rekrutenschule
da ist in hoch spitze und dienst am
bürger sind die eu muss die
rekrutenschule nach stift gemacht haben
dann auch gewisse güter und wer also die
tore haben wir drei meter schnee
garantiert morgen schützen russ chris de
burgh wendet hat sich richtig hin und
auf der wache hat man es also noch mal
abstand verlegt mit dem zug fahren
zusammen richtig gott hat zurück in die
gegend und zu den erinnerungen wo der
85-jährige sulzberger
[Musik]
sachsens tag lang ist ewald roth im
gotthardgebiet im aktivdienst ziehen
[Musik]
später hätte sagt der rückschau wird bis
zum feldwebel das bild vom weltraum aus
junger soldat oberhaupt vor ihrer op der
ehemalige fechtig treffen rena vor der
letzte kommandanten wo da noch bis zum 7
sg chemie zeitz ii
das ist daher auch das ist damit als
rustico zugang zum werk vom band rollt
clinch der werke wurde gotthard
befestigungen er fertig war wollte
vertraut ist das ist zwar flog als sie
dort immer es kontrollen gemacht wurde
wenn berlin das werk i never had wähler
hätten sie einen ausweis zeigen und
swiss ski mit der front ruf und den
hebräischen ihnen dürfe das
artilleriefeuer grandezza 100 minute
ließ bauer um mit waffe nach flüchtet
worden
nur gerade das jahr jetzt man braucht
wird fest ich fand es bauer dankte sie
für raumschiffe zu tätigen als
faschistische italien nummer 14
kilometer von dem ort weg
[Musik]
die stetige für schneider auch bei heads
militär aus uhr regelte schweizer
vorteil liegt die waghalsige manöver
herzberg wirbt das schwierige klandt zu
tätigen
das in die strategie der eclipse mit tv
movie klein so hoch wie möglich
fortsetzen
mit strom würde tweets flacher und rarer
holland darüber liegen
bis dann muss sie sie während der woche
der festigen punkte zu das kann ich mir
gut vorstellen
und wenn's schlimm vor die letzten
gemüse probieren wie es der im krieg wo
da um die zeugung zwar warnt woche den
klappte
ohne große kontakt zur familie freunde
und engagiert begleitet klar warum sie
glauben dass schweiz vom krieg verschont
bleiben ist ein grund ist sicher sie
darm brands aktie den widerstand leisten
nachher industriegebiet industrieanlagen
die mittel an der weher beschädigt dem
intel wlan unbrauchbar machen
vorbereitet sie sind hätte ich mir vor
alba kämpfen wo auch mit fest ins werk
bestückt sie in spring objekt 1 noch auf
andere und wenn er denn wirklich zum
gotthard und wer dennoch hätte man eben
oder tunnel und stress können springen
dass die römer passiert passive symbole
und der grund hat noch weniger der grund
so zwischen dem sv erhalten die
hauptstadt wenn ihr genau wisst luft
also wie der kopf hatten die magic luft
flogen
in der stunde und erregt die quote nur
hofer truppe setzte und gegenleistung
schnitt sind das ist einfach der
strategie des hohen eintrittspreise sven
mietmodell klarheit sondern auch er noch
ist das wieder betriebe worden
das ist wichtig auch liege aber er auch
das aus hypothetisch glaube dir wirklich
trat das wird sowie dass das war ein
nützliches strategie
es habe ja nichts es ist los gegangen
auch noch her kalte klebt das ist im
sicherheitsbericht von 370 ich immer
denen das größte teil vom staatsgebiet
kalter werden muss das wäre zwar tief
bei seinem job als halter und halten
kann man das stark-gelände stark ist und
das ist nun in gottes namen einmal ist
das ewig so gehen etwas drängt sich
verfassen
aber der war die partei hier hat dass
man auch große teile halten kann
stelzer von gott hat bis zum simplen vom
nufenen bis sa ganz extrem vw das bild
tiger angriff vom schweizer blick pieper
[Musik]
frau und freunde hat ihm entsteht
praktisch schutzlos zurück
[Musik]
gigantische bunkeranlage der berge
riesige fest ich wollte schwer
bewaffneten geschützt
das ist fertig
wer nie mehr aus besitzt etwa
überlagerte falsch war die idee bis zur
letzten konsequenz nachvollziehen
klicken sie hier
gegen die jetzt geordnet von der mutter
und dann hier warten
dabei wissen was da drinnen passiert ist
mache ich politik sehen
dort wurde ja der wichtigsten spricht
der wagen kostet und sieht einfach unten
herum sagte unicef
jawohl der typische story bieten also
quasi internet nismo des nickels
verurteilt
der größte thema um andere macht und wo
man ihnen das leid aus ab juni die
marinesparte zeit zurück gekommen und
dann ist man natürlich halt sachen optik
bietet worden dass man hat durch gott
hat im bund dürfe die entstehung im
panzer turm kommen die zwar relativ
gesamte geschützt sind selber mag sie
aus spezialisten bringt auf die einzelne
aufgabe dass ich an einer stelle ja da
ist hofer möglichkeit der kölner fall
sind eric hettmann können die stele
merkel in einer falle ändert ruft nur
sein können sie denn richtig macht
richtig alles vor chrome ein armee war
es auch im gebirge fährst du forderst
vaterland verteidigen schrumpft auf
eines dieses kerngebiet bis mit der
heutige möglichen betrugs lagern und
dankbar weil das ist rock
antwort über kommen im bundeshaus beim
obersten chef vom militär im bundesrat
ueli maurer dem amtsantritt vor einem
halben jahr verkündeten die beste armee
vor lüthi steht nicht einfach sondern
ist verstärkung entlang vom plant rom
stark ist und mir würde zusammenstellt
nur militärisch osten versuchen
abschotten oder verteidigungslinien
aufbau möglichst gute chance hat und
tritt wahrscheinlich bis naturgeister
ist man das ist ein natürlicher
abschnitt mit mit der berge mit raupen
meter lang ist und ganz auf die große
wiese winter und unerfahren sondern
mitgeteilt ohne sich oder muss oder will
haben beim kestler und tritt
wesentliches aber letztendlich hat das
ganze mittelland
das wären höhere preise aber musste der
damalige zeit eigentlich dreht wie
gedanke hat vertrauen zurück glauben an
die eigenen verteidigungsfähigkeiten
verteidigungsmöglichkeiten
darum ist tritt wie auch psychologische
aspekte und darum ob das wirklich hübsch
wenn das kühlkette täter es geschafft
hatten es geschafft bin ich überzeugt
zügig vom bundesrat bezüglich der
wehrhaftigkeit ist klar
mini vermutet der historiker bild mit
dem nicht ganz verstanden
[Musik]
unsere sicht was hättest vom krieg
verschont langfristig ist ganz wichtig
dass tweets nicht überlebt hat als
demokratischer staat als das land wo sie
sich selbst wenn die alliierten die
dämpfen haben sage schweiz verdankt er
das überleben und ihres verschont bliebe
tricks völlig von der alliierte was man
eigentlich in der schweiz doch sehr
wenig zur kenntnis genommen hat will man
sehr stark davon ausgegangen ist dass
die eigene jahre medien
abschreckungswirkung sollte wenn man
aber wiederum legt wie julian griffs
plan wo einfach planlos geschafft hätte
das jede generell jede generalstab macht
das die reine somit ganze bezugssystem
vorteile schweizer kato der plan
zimmermann von 448 deutschland wenn es
so sein freie kapazität da steht drin
dass schweizer soldaten sich stark wird
wäre das die eigentlich recht geübt sind
die kriegsführung obwohl der schweiz
vergeben
dass sie aber durch ruß in sachen
widerstandsgeist otto in der bar gleich
am schluss heißt aber es erscheint daher
zumindest zweifelhaft ob sich die
schweiz einem gemeinsamen militärischen
vorgehen deutschlands und italiens
gegenüber zum kauf stellen wird ein
nachgeben erscheint wahrscheinlich
sondern oft wirtschaft
[Musik]
nachdem red wie berichtet der general
quichote armee vor 450 550 money medien
schlecht ist er willkommen arbeitskraft
es hätte wirtschaft koffer mit den alt
rocker sind arbeitsplätze die produktion
mit der schweiz
august in deutschland einen
wirtschaftsverträge macht das ist ein
großes vertrags immer wieder schweiz die
import gewährleistet unter anderem um
den ständig uns zwar das so hält man
eine schöne ein wirtschaftlicher
kooperation in deutschland auch mit
anderen länder und durch italien der
schweiz und den ganzen weg versucht rund
ums leben deutschland ist aber eindeutig
das wichtigste abnehmerland auf verkäufe
für werkzeugmaschinen für kriegswichtige
güter wurde mich an sagen würde diese
hätte zweimal gar nicht so stark im
vordergrund gerückt
mehr darf aber nicht vergessen dass er
selber drei wochen noch im rapport
vorgeschlagen sonderbotschafter bei
linken bereich zum hitler
wo hat die müsse die schweizerisch
wirtschaftsleistung nach deutschland
auch kobler und da ist der bundesrat sei
damovo das ablehnten
so verfolgte doppelstrategie volk mit
zündender ideen rät die psychologin
stärken und gleichzeitig wirtschaftlich
mit der usa macht kooperiere raum mit
nazi deutschlands
ein nachmittag der frühling am zürichsee
sorge in der auguststraße vom restaurant
winzerhof trafen sich vertreter von der
gruppe aktiv zur kompanie tadic es ist
nun an ausschließlich jahr - und hier
treffen wir wieder auf den wert bis auf
die letzte zahl ganz sicher ganz sicher
hätte ich mir ich anna ortswehr gemacht
ich kann mit mit 15 jahren es quält von
48 munition fast in die akte mit
armbinde und ein stahlhelm mehr an den
start der härter ist ausbildet im wald
als für verteidigung und so hat man
eigentlich ein wille da einfach der
böses vaterland sagte werden nicht
schweigen konnte heimat und oliver krise
alles ist tipptop dem und die manier in
varese gradestraße dass man im fall der
dgvm auch kommt dass sie nicht wissen
konnte wurde das lenkrad gesehen hätte
es der guardian hat dann nehmen die
dagong haben wir auch so nur dass nik
century weiß neubauten stadt konstanz
und studenten
[Gelächter]
exportiert ist ein offizieller zitiert
man sich nicht im richtigen moment also
richtig verhalten hat und hat sich dann
auch herausgestellt dass er die entfällt
sogar hinter roxy der nationalen front
mitgemacht hat das ist der direkte
vertreter dann hat das engagement der
eltern mit bahnhof ist nicht immer alles
so glänzend club in erik tankwagen aus
schöne bild mich mit und naumburg ordner
schlimme vergessen gegangen
[Musik]
jetzt plant beleidigung und dass wir das
einfach gibt es zudem das ist schon
jetzt zur diskussion und die schweiz das
stachelschwein das nehmen wir dem
heimweg ein
aber ich hatte nicht stattgefunden
direkter der bahnlinie gotthard und der
tanz cholera durchgeführt ganze und
zwischen ihnen hat dieser branche fest
aber pocket opera sind durch niedrigen
als munition sie das gemacht und die
haben schwer material hin und
hergeschoben zu und nach italien aber
das ist eigentlich trumpf schied die so
wichtige nord-süd-verbindung sie
garantiert im landtag muss aber
natürlich ort ständig zwischen
deutschland und italien
[Musik]
die wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit für
die schiedsfrau mit deutschlandweiten
tricks jahr bislang weitgehend ohne
furcht blieben
er schnitt ins parlament auf
internationaler druck die so genannte
beige kommission eingesetzt wo drohen
schweiz zweiter weltkrieg umfassend
hetze ruf arbeiten im jahr 2002 ist er
schloss richtung schweiz auch zum ersten
mal themen wie rob gut nachrichtenlose
vermögen wirtschaftlichen kooperation
mit deutschland und der umstrittene
flüchtlingspolitik
aachen
port elizabeth die kommission hat er
wohl gruppe gemäßigter untergeordnet ist
man sich mal vorstellen
der unterbruch drin und haben wir
rohstoffanteil sektor stark sich holen
wird es ist dann raus müssen
innerhofer sache in der europäischen
kommission ab rang red werden babys
buffer liefere hier also flügel wird
schild nach deutschland das ist nach der
haager konvention ist das durchaus in
ordnung privat zu privat nutze landgüter
verlief positiv und gleichzeitig zum
ausdruck die damalige und herzlich von
der bevölkerung sie können es gar nicht
begriffen dass es ist überhaupt also
grüßen ist auch so schlimm
sie sind nicht so schlimm ja die ganze
situation wir sind ja eigentlich gehört
ihm in die zweite mobile mache ich sie
mir ja wert lag sie konnte und da haben
wir jeden tag meine gäste erzielte
tiefer ganz los nicht hatte einfach nur
zehn teilnehmer richtig schlafen möchten
wir euch ruft sie und alles ist nervös
sind sich der situation sie wo man sich
heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen die sie
dann bricht wurde findet das treffen auf
schloss zeichen wahrheiten zu marian der
brief liegt weisen sind ja ich weiß
nicht 12 30 sieht januar kann tiger
bekanntlich fototaschen natürlich ein
ruhmesblatt aber das hätte konferenz wo
ibm schweiz hat sich erklärt jüdische
flüchtlinge aber sie müssten wieder
weiterreisen
unisono in alle krieg nein kommt nicht
in frage
ich glaube chile hat noch zeit wollten
die andere seite wo bruder sind pte pte
der treburer kann und dennoch keine
krise könnte nur her wenn alle da sind
wir viel zehnter scirocco bevölkerung
verdoppelt wenn man alle chlorierten wo
es nötig hätten
dann bricht mit geschaufelt oder
historiker jakob tanner kritik ist
rogans die aktin gelichtet
[Musik]
ich selber wenig verständnis haben das
ist so einfach ein pauschaler abhängig
vom ergebnis und der berufene mythos wo
ein lager sind gestiftet hätten sich
einfach sagen ich heiße story keine
andere funktion haben kritische funktion
und ich muss irgendwie versuchen
forschungsergebnisse plausibel zu machen
aber ich habe noch eine
geschichtsklitterung betrieben und sagen
irgendwo ja genau so ist sie wenn ich
das so formulieren heißt das dass sich
noch im krieg müsse stelle noch der
befragten reagierte hat schweizer
meisters eigenes büro aber mit moralisch
sehr höchstens irgendwann ein anders
könnte machen will
wir sind abhängig von einer
wirtschaftsbeziehungen
und wenn wir die zeit nur wenig
spielraum k da muss natürlich sagen dass
man die deutschland über eine milliarde
ppb gold ab auf zum größten planen
konnte abkauft das ist nicht so wichtig
2 0 das ist ein witz wie kann ich sehen
dass ich bereitschaft sie einfach musik
spielt die kooperation einfach so
business as usual mäßig widgets für mit
der flüchtlingspolitik hat alternative
der schweiz nicht das volle buchse wo
sie sich selber denn aus dem plastik
argument dargestellten der
nachrichtenlosen vermögen hat man schon
erahnen dem krieg überlegen wie gut man
noch möglich mit dem um
die sieht münster bis zum einen die vom
krieg schweizer des verbundes strategie
fest karte hätte diego mentalität pflegt
und auf die kälber festigen
in der bar gesetzt vom waage kanton uri
auf arm stark dadurch hinter versteckter
oder zwingli und bis vier partner jahr
absolut cam ist die prämie stoller der
ehemalige bundesrats großen zweite
weltkrieg der erst was ihr gar hätte der
schweiz nummer 1 ist der bundesrat
wirklich sexy am theater november
münster 14 am heck elisabeth drehs
tochter vor dem start wird wo denn führt
gesellschaft eingebracht und personal
und da habe ich noch einen sieg wieviel
trier und nachtragshaushalt das
fröhliches fest wurde im bundesrat
halten kursen ab trachten und er als die
eine ding das ist ja lustig
die zwiebeln ich mich eine bürgerin die
sind auch sondern sangesfreudige sich
vorstellen über kaffee meter das tor
super hat verkannt stimmen
nicht weit vom weg zu samstag ist der
ehemalige bundesrat burkhalter zeigt
patterson bunkern art riesiger presse
gemacht und in barcas verschwieg nicht
geschafft für
sicherheitsdienstleistungen aufbaue
bis 11
mit von partie ist moritz novi sa der
architekt auftrag vom bund auch
militärische festung sein lager
inventarisiert
stoller hier die chance genau wie das
ist vermutlich aber so in die nahe es
gibt keine weiter und das ist form zu
kommen
das ist eine dimension von dem boom
kräftig im ernstfall hat die hier in der
nabe des bundesrats 0 372 menschen platz
bot dazu 120 otto und ritter lauscht
wacker
besucher von banken offenbar zu tief
oder caravan erzeugt komplett andere
konstruktion
sie sind jetzt in eure
und hinten diese wende versteckt sich
diese sehr selten eine große sind im
schweiz zeigt die holzkonstruktion das
ist sehr sehr sehr speziell und
besonders in schwarz
heimelig wie immer richtige chance ist
eine vom bunker geld komplett verloren
rüstet das 2 1 mit aussicht fahrertür
stehen wie ihre romantische skilager
hüther dieser war im berner oberland und
hätte man das bundes hat im rosental
oder im kanton uri gehabt das ist schon
die erste besonderheit als erste vom
dieses dass man entscheidet sich
regierungsboot das hätte man getrennt
die zweite ist die innere konstruktion
mit dieser zweistöckige charlie ist auch
wenn nicht einmal ich relativ selten
oder sehr selten im schweiz und
natürlich die dritte das ist eine
erektion genutzte anlage das ist doch
interessant zu sehen dass man kann
einmal schutz mit erhaltung ziele und
mit wirtschaftlicher ziele auch erreicht
hätte kostet das da hier der bundesrat
punkte inhaltes dass eigentlich niemand
christi chefs bekommt wurde nach dem
prozess vom 5 das effektive so dass das
was ist mit einem sind willkommen bekam
sie selber weiß natürlich auch so die
sache
ja die alten bereite den tresor uno für
die schweizerische nationalbank braucht
wurden ich bin inzwischen ins kosovo
denn das wichtig private sicher gegangen
ist und auch teilweise nicht klar was
die nation in der zweiten und regen dem
frau kabelsenders kundgebung sehr wenig
vom bunker hetzendorf wie für chassis
und empathie deiner historische rüben
sind gäste
rechte hetzer hochmodernes ball und für
tradition vom verschwiegene geschäft
wittern eine panzertür hätte
verschiedenste sachen im wert von
milliarden sicherheiten kunst schmuck
sensible daten von banken und
versicherungen
[Musik]
wieviel boom kräftig erhöht um bauer sie
für die öffentlichkeit zugänglich oder
gang ein camp für das gar nichts büro
von oslo visa
[Musik]
versteckt an gott da war eine größere
festung im zweiten weltkrieg gebaut saß
oder tina ich könnte natürlich diese
nicht sehen der verein das anders werden
sollte das nichts besuchen
ich habe ein paar jahre später diese
gesehen und ich muss sagen ich bin fast
ein bisschen enttäuscht geblieben und
deswegen sage ich die miete muss man
nicht zerstören die kräfte der mythos
ist viel wichtiger als die realität
es ist viel wichtiger dass große sache
cambridge ich würde sagen nicht wegen
politischer aspekt aber wegen sagen wir
das psychologische bewusst um die
menschen vielleicht ja aber jetzt ist
fast alles noch nicht aber es habe viele
ja das ist was ich weiß nicht was
wahrscheinlich die kleinste objekte die
darüber bin ich vielleicht selbst nicht
im wind es soll genau ist das nicht
außerdem es gibt vielleicht einige
objekte dienen so geheim dass es gibt
sehr sehr wenig leute die können
effektiv wo sie sind und wofür sie sieht
und den stopps objekt geht wohne ich
vorenthalten
ich kenne eigentlich schade aber
vielleicht gibt es einige die sind so
gut versteckt dass fast niemand mehr
weiß wo sie sind
es geht immer noch eröffnet doch zog
eigentlich schon zweite ist dass die so
genannte was müsste dir siehst deine
anlage im raum
kanton uri und ist wie effektiv gesagt
noch nicht veröffentlicht
deswegen darf ich nicht sagen ich habe
natürlich eine verpflichtung abkommen
mit vbs
ich kann sagen wir haben das studiert es
gibt interessante aspekte aber wie bei
bestimmte bunker die haben ein interesse
für bunds diese ist noch nicht so
genannte und klassifiziert und deswegen
sollen wir noch ein bisschen darüber
schweigen das objekt wird zwar
vielleicht jeweilige riesig aber genug
schwicker basset al megrahi nutzt und
armee hat das sensitive materialien
während vorratshaltung stamme flut sowie
spieler pedro und für größte lager
möglichkeiten sich durch hussing machen
darum weiter relativ wenig aber in
zukunft einfach betrieben als lager als
ob man in gedanken zweite weltkrieg habe
mich nur ich hätte festigen
ich weiß nicht was ich gewollt hätte
würde er noch so dick sind so gut die
türe anlage und sie sind gut sie sind im
v8 kann
also was soll ich sie vor fahrer bog an
der technischen richtige sicher bleibt
so die feste sind da und technische
grundstücke die emission von rund 300
schutz stelle wenn es mit anderer
maßstab ist und sich dabei einige unter
schutz gestellt sogar es heute einfacher
hof wurde das ist problem also wieder
rutschte fragt wer würde ich sagen wir
halten alle im betrieb aber sicher
fragen zu ist wichtig
man sieht fern und ist nur ein teil
deines kein problem da ist klar sie weiß
mario viel wichtiger sind sie
aber wer weiß nicht wie viele lytwyn mit
wälder war von boris und beendete sie
das was sie selbst bereit
die chemnitz vfl gladbeck reform sieht
die angefangen hat mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen gäste der name der summe
micronas filmteam italien
spätestens vor dem tee wäre der stick
ist länger geworden und am schluss als
kaiser den drei absolut ausgeschlossen
im nördlich von der berühmten duisburg
soll eine schlucht geht's los sein
van den bergh buffet das dahinter steckt
tatsächlich riesige fest ich muss sie
aber vielleicht ist es aber doch so
bemüht die sache kam liebe gott hat wird
ganz offensichtlich nicht aus chemnitz
priester
[Musik]
[Gelächter]